[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لنا سماع مثل هذه الاخبار يعتبر
بادره امل ومحفز كبير جدا
للشباب الذي يبحث عن اثبات ذاته واثبات
نفسه في ميادين كانت حصرا على مجتمعات
معينه
والشباب العربي اثبت قدرته الكبيره جدا
المعرفيه والمهنيه والحرفيه من ناحيه
المهارات التي اكتسبها لتطوير بلدانهم زي
ما ذكرت في التقرير ومثال نستجيب اللي
ذكرته في التقرير مثال مشرف لنا جميعا
كعرب ويثبت انه نهضه بلداننا لن تتم الا
بسواعد ابنائنا
[موسيقى]
احد يعني الاهداف المعلنه والغير معلنه
لدعم الشركات التقنيه الناشئه في في مختلف
البلدان هو لتنميه اقتصادياتها
يعني من دخول مستثمرين
لشركات تقنيه محليه سواء في السعوديه او
في الامارات او في مصر او في تونس او
غيرها من البلدان العربيه اكبر دليل على
يعني
الرؤيه الواضحه لدعم مثل هذه الشركات منذ
نشاتها وهو بالفعل يدعم اقتصاديات المنطقه
ويجلب استثمارات
للمنطقه ويدعم كذلك المهارات المطلوبه
لتنميه وانشاء مثل الشركات التقنيه التي
تخدم مجتمعاتنا والمجتمع بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]